and excited
ready to go the next up we're going to
we were going Star Wars launch Bay Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning believe nation where we off
two guys I jump out the energy level
guys if you like to come up a little bit
but we'll save it for later is day six
we're up early today it was a normal
because you need to get in line the Jedi
training thing that has limited seating
that all the kids running shoes we got
to get there sure that we have hard to
do it I had a dream last night that I
was accidentally hosting two events
indistinct
very stressful less than something
happen to everybody to be happy but I
woke up and I have the non stress of
planning our disney vacation so that can
get getting all these guys ready in the
morning right that's not stressful right
it's easy it's just tell the kid to do
it once and then we get done here we go
Hollywood studio look at that morning
sunrise Disney's Hollywood Studios very
exciting all right we made it there's
almost nobody here is very exciting
we're going to get our Jedi training
spot if we didn't get Jedi training the
kids to be very upset freaky nice so
plan is get to the entrance here when
they let us in Nina and the kids go to
Jedi training the lineup husband goes
and get some coffee cuz Nina wants
coffee yeah you do maybe today no coffee
too sweet oh wow okay well then we're
going to get some coffee pnina because
we love her you guys ready yeah all
right let's go all right we made it one
of the first people
spend an hour in line waiting to do so
but the person to the dimension ain't
Cartman minimize the line I mean I mean
let's go the kids are running Jedi look
at the lineup establish 30 longer than
anyone that field because oh the past
things to do to love right Nina's dead
we have she would have to the company
she does a lot done a lot so I suppose
to keep everybody joke and I on track
[Music]
you got to get there to get into the
good news you know has her coffee drink
up yeah me going to get to meet hola
again your friends yeah good idea yeah
all right Jedi training time you ready
hate it
we're going you excited what are you
gonna do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's see your ready position like that
/ let's hear it cut to the head do the
whole thing now alright name is getting
her acceptance ending in line
[Music]
here we go
you
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you think of this one they changed it
[Applause]
[Music]
was the better or worse
[Music]
next up we're going to we were going Oh
Star Wars launch Bay oh wow that's the
excitement that the excitement friends
the savage the excitement dick free next
up Star Wars launch Bay yeah that's I'm
talking about
[Music]
[Music]
alright are we ready for lunch ready for
lunch we're going to have some gourmet
inspired hot dogs in a new place see how
you do it we might have fun tell Nina
Nina time for some gourmet hot dog hi
gourmet hot dog place yeah you know look
Nina looks very excited by this very
excited
[Music]
all right time to eat we got our clock
and our sour cream and our humongous hot
dogs and not just to everybody have a
bite guys hi
all right enjoy guys it's finally warmed
up enough to wear t-shirt he should
whether we're gonna watch the artwork so
now
[Music]
if you like that all right it's muffin
time I like this one
[Music]
with that fine young now we're literally
somewhere this time use our first time
our tours all right Walton's excited all
right so too in the inside
[Music]
how was it not very good yeah so much
fun how about you Nina I feel a little
nauseous comfortable knocking oh you
feel nauseous what did you say that I'm
good nap that's left inna scratch here
for your eyes which you can nap stop you
little harsh and you're getting it
changed it up again I wouldn't any
mother father like well anyway okay did
they continue now we're going to go
watch the Star Wars movie the new one
here we go
Nina totally passed that she had her
head on my shoulder that has United the
proper up just kept falling down the
runway for Luke and Leia are sisters go
next up frozen let it go let's tell
Stephanie next up frozen let it go how
do you know you just know I you know
everything cuz your Haven Carmichael I
don't mind that I and no
[Music]
[Laughter]
ready now
bothered me anyway
Oh
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
your sing-along I was it okay next up
Indiana Jones
[Music]
Oh
good
[Music]
what did you think mr. yeah who's your
favorite part
nice how did it look
do a demonstration
[Music]
where the boys is Hayden so we just we
just finished Indiana Jones and no we're
doing that what do we think our cozy ice
cream honey I magazine gummy he is one
thing left you know what it is Toy Story
ride
[Music]
someone's enjoying this vanilla ice
cream and stoning that at the same time
hello no
hey baby should i can eat it
bye
[Music]
Nina Kratz update on Pokemon what did
you catch wow you got a cloud the dark
hair hurry up Angela project these guys
are obsessed with pokemon go you can
catch different pokemon cards what we
get in Toronto meme is leading the
charge in this insanity but I support it
because you love Nina and without the
kids and so with them have been fun so
this is lem heaven five did you get it
yes good high five good job baby you
know very high mr. family have here
comes here it is high five that up so
[Music]
final stop is the Toy Story ride where
we go with our 3d glasses and fight off
the enemy I won't be able to film inside
but again i'm looking forward to
defending my store on our last rides at
disney work who's excited ride hello Jed
I hate it excited all right deckers
excited even tried is excited Oh watch
is really ready it's just a game face
look to your game face what seeing that
believe they should give me an opinion
in the comments listening in the
comments excited
ready to go let's do it we're on their
stories
I took that one
dining sensitive vehicle that's it now
our holy fasting are 463 went crazy
I got a lot would you get 131,000 131
kitty well below 32 thousand would you
be Jeffrey Stefan is 80 almost you know
yeah I'm hating
good job guys wiki 185 thousand listen
it's not about winning it's about
playing right and it's about running
really about winning playing for
everyone ok we're going to have fun yeah
so thinking of joining us per day yeah
same six tomorrow we are off to
Universal Studios hope you enjoyed this
video like we enjoy today you continue
to I will see you soon and whatever you
want Oh